après 55 ans de lune de miel entre
disney et l'état de la floride l'heure
est aux règlements de comptes
depuis que disney a condamné la loi sur
l'éducation du gouvernement de santis
leur communiqué était sans équivoque
votre loi dont seguer doit être
supprimée écrit la compagnie et n'aurait
jamais dû devenir loi notre objectif est
de l'abolir par le biais des
législateurs ou des tribunaux la guerre
est donc déclarée c'est mickey mouse
contre roanne de santis le très
populaire gouverneur républicain qui du
même coup vient de signer une loi qui
retire les privilèges du disney en
floride
[Applaudissements]
19ème invité dans notre état dit il
voire minded est mauvais on le leur a
rappelé ses 6,8 à l'échelle ce sont des
représailles contre la liberté
d'expression dans sa nasse camani
disney veut protéger la communauté lgbt
disney envoie un message très clair au
gouvernement nous dit ouest idée
je suis très fier de leur prise de
position dit-il et j'espère qu'ils vont
continuer dans cette voie
car la communauté a été touchée de près
par l'homophobie orlando a été la scène
d'une tuerie ce mémorial en plein coeur
de la ville en est un tragique rappelle
c'est ici en 2016 dans cette ancienne
boîte de nuit surtout fréquenté par la
communauté gay qu'un tireur fou a tué 49
personnes et la compagnie disney a donné
1 million de dollars pour venir en aide
à la fondation des familles des victimes
pour beaucoup la nouvelle loi de santis
intitulé le droit des parents en
éducation ravive l'homophobie la loire
baptisé don't say gay ne parlait pas des
gays interdit toute discussion sur
l'orientation ou l'identité sexuelle à
l'école primaire une loi qui ne fait que
justifier l'homophobie est d'abord celle
des
indigènes qui a rédigé la loi sur le
droit des parents se défend affirmant
qu'elle n'a rien d'homophobe
les enfants besoin d'apprendre la
lecture les maths les sciences dites ils
n'ont pas besoin d'être endoctrinés dans
des théories sexuelle à l'âge de 6 ans
pourtant l'éducation sexuelle n'est
enseignée qu'à partir de la sixième
année dans les écoles publiques en
floride un sac sur rising sun annonce
que manny va plus loin
ils ont créé un faux problème dit elle
ils prétendent avoir éliminé un problème
qui n'a jamais voté pour bada s'appelle
espère qu'ils pourront philly fed
que va-t-on dire aux enfants qu'ils se
sentent différents on est en train de
leur dire que ce qu'ils ressentent n'est
pas normal
nous sommes en guerre pour l'âme de
notre pays dans ce rallye fans dow kraft
et brûlots nazis pipo
et une fois leur tactique sera carrément
we fight night
républicains et démocrates s'entre
déchirent et l'entreprise disney qui a
l'habitude d'éviter tout débat politique
se retrouve prise entre l'opinion
publique des politiciens et ses intérêts
d'affaires
pour jacques
rogge a écrit un livre sur la relation
entre disney et orlando marie tooth de
mars marié à la souris de
disney doit faire attention dit il sa
marque de commerce est son talon
d'achille
c'est une source de faiblesse pour
disney doit être à la hauteur de sa
marque lundi fans n'en démord pas 10
n'est allé trop loin ce dernier cède que
notre force
l'entreprise va imposer les valeurs de
la californie aux électeurs de la
floride au titre holzner oui oui oise
quand ils ont mis le feu aux poudres on
s'est rendu compte qu'ils avaient des
privilèges que nul autre entreprise non
c'est que disney est une société
distincte à l'intérieur de la floride
l'entreprise contrôler un territoire de
100 kilomètres carrés appelé rudy creek
près d'orlando à peine sommes-nous
entrés dans ce monde merveilleux que les
panneaux change de couleur mais les
juridictions aussi disney assurent les
services publics comme les pompiers la
voirie le ramassage des ordures en
échange l'entreprise est exempté de la
plupart des règlementations de l'état je
vais vivre plus longtemps que toi des
mickeys à 206 sur cette caricature un
bras de fer qui pourrait durer un an car
la révocation du statut spécial de
l'entreprise notre en vigueur qu'en juin
il s'est abonné guirguis radio-canada
orlando floride